i'm fairly certain social media is
making us all [ __ ]
you should reclassify facebook to what
it is an
anti-social network
and yesterday twitter went full [ __ ]
i have joined isis guys
i didn't think it was that big a deal
but a lot of people seem to think so
different news outlets posted about this
and you might be wondering why why did
pewdiepie join isis
how could he do that i thought he was
just a
youtuber from sweden how could he do
this how can he betray us like this
isis that doesn't make any sense well
let me explain
damn it let's start from the beginning
you know verified on twitter
that little blue check mark that people
have which
people seem to use as some form of
status symbol now
you got the blue check mark you're
[ __ ] cool all right
people write [ __ ] about it in their bio
being like it's not a big deal
i am verified but i don't really know
why i know why i'm [ __ ]
i'm the [ __ ] coolest [ __ ] ever
oh this verified tick mark not a big
deal
if you're wondering why i'm verified i
don't know i don't really know
i honestly like what did i do that tick
doesn't mean that i'm important
yes it [ __ ] does it just means
i'm me now why do people want this check
mark i don't know
if anyone with a blue check mark
interact with you in any way
possible you get a notification on your
phone so let's say
taylor swift tweets at me i'll get a
notification about it now a lot of
people do
what they do is they'll just start
following you hoping that you will
follow back
if you follow more people it basically
means
that you get recommended to be followed
by other people
twitter has this who to follow
suggestions if you follow a lot of
people
you're likely to show up i'll show you
some experts
we have melissa joan hart you remember
sabrina the teenage witch
she follows 200 000 people she follows
me for some reason
i'm sure she's a big fan 200 [ __ ]
thousand
times she clicked follow oh we get worse
bart baker 570 000 following
you're following five you're following
almost more people than follows you
what the [ __ ] you have someone hired
like a little sweatshop
person to just click follow for you i
don't understand
okay you know what fine you know it's
not hurting anyone i don't care
but one thing that i think is a little
funny it's like when you follow
451 000 people you're a youtuber
but you make it your business to make
sure that you don't
follow pewdiepie you know i'm gonna
follow a half a million people but
pewdiepie
[ __ ] that guy not gonna follow that guy
okay this video is getting sidetracked
let me get back to my point
i think we can all agree that this is
just [ __ ] annoying well it gets worse
there's people that
will follow you and then they will
unfollow you
and then they'll follow you again and
then they'll unfollow you and then you
follow you again so you keep getting
notifications
they hope that you will notice you and
follow back well guess not no i see the
notifications i'm not going to follow
back
why is this a thing i don't know how
this started
but people basically
i'll see this in my notifications and i
like to tweet you were mentioned i'm
like oh okay that's cool
oh so she liked a fan post she doesn't
even follow me
why the [ __ ] would you like a fan tweet
why would you do you're blocked
okay now with verification process being
just [ __ ] annoying i decided to
unverify myself
yes it is possible now i did this
yesterday as a joke it was really funny
because you can see a lot of people
joined in
i added the globe instead and that's my
new that's the real notification from
now on
but then america woke up
that's when [ __ ] got stupid so this fake
obviously fake
website called sky news which ironically
enough is not verified as well so
everyone was wondering
why the [ __ ] did he unverify himself
everyone who didn't understand the joke
and wanting a reason so badly they would
believe anything
so sky news posted popular youtuber
pewdiepie and verified due to suspected
relations with isis seems legit right
you click on the news story oh it just
goes to
it just goes to a random article that's
great that would
that would have taken anyone like one
half a second so people started
believing this that i joined
isis what the [ __ ] are you doing
obviously what the [ __ ]
are you doing and ironically enough this
sky news
is obviously a fake and it's not
verified so it really proves the point
how verified really makes all the
difference it's really a
effective system to distinguish the fake
accounts from the real ones
because clearly no one believe no one
everyone saw that this was not verified
and they
thought to themself wow that is not
verified this article about pewdiepie
joining isis that just can't be real
because it's not a verified account and
i can see that because it doesn't have
the verified tick mark
clearly it doesn't even [ __ ] work
seeing how stupid this was i tweeted a
joke saying me and jack join isis which
is why we both got unverified
and everyone just started freaking out
so dumb
why am i here mashable posted about it
people are freaking out they even
reached out to jack who had literally
nothing to do with it
could you comment about this story about
pewdiepie joining isis
man being a journalist must really be a
fulfilling
work i think we can summarize this
entire video as in does this [ __ ]
[ __ ] matter absolutely not now i
invite you to join
and be globified as i like to call it
which by the way is way [ __ ] cooler
than verified thank you very much i
don't know why i got globified or who i
am honestly
i still don't know guys my globified
tick
it doesn't mean i'm important it just
means i'm me
now i invite you to become globified as
well really what the globe means
is my ranking in isis you start off with
the globe and then
you could potentially move up to the
blue flower thing and if you're real
lucky
you can have the popcorn